en el vídeo pasado estábamos hablando
acerca del interés compuesto y llegamos
a la fórmula que nos decía que si tenías
un principal hilo invertidas en cierto
período entonces la cantidad interés que
tenías que pagar si el banquero o la
institución crediticia te prestaba un
peso a un interés del 100 por ciento
durante en periodos de periodos entonces
ésta era la fórmula que tenía que usar
por ejemplo si sólo usaban un periodo un
periodo imposición entonces pagaban el
100 por ciento durante ese periodo si
tenía dos periodos de imposición
entonces tenías que pagar uno más un
medio al cuadrado que sería 2.25
etcétera etcétera y lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es tratar de ver que en
verdad nos estamos acercando a un valor
definido así que déjenme saco mi
calculadora y bueno en el vídeo pasado
llegamos hasta 365 ahora quiero usar
números aún más grandes vamos a ver
vamos a escribir
1 más 1 /
/ vamos a decir un millón 123 1 2 3 un
millón y todo eso lo elevamos a la
potencia de un millón 123 1 2 3 ok y
justo antes de que presiona enter y me
dé el resultado la calculadora vamos a
pensar qué es lo que está pasando aquí
tengo un número 1 entre n que se está
haciendo cada vez más pequeño así que
esta parte de aquí se está acercando
cada vez más a 1 así que aunque le vea
una potencia gigantesca como en este
caso aunque le ve un millón este número
como está muy cercano uno quizás no sea
un número tan tan grande y descabellado
veamos
aquí lo tenemos 2 puntos 71 82 80
etcétera etcétera
qué pasa si usa un número aún más grande
vamos a usar de hecho vamos a usar
notación científica así que uno entre
qué les parece 10 millones
a las siete esto significa 10 millones
así que elevó a la potencia 1
a la diezmillonésima potencia en cuanto
nos da eso nos da dos puntos 71 82 81
etcétera ven como este número se fue
acercando un valor definido vamos a
hacer 100 millones
no más 1 / mismo
por 10 a la 8 todo es elevado a la 1 por
10 al 8
muy bien así que vamos acercándonos a
este número que de hecho este número en
la calculadora nos dice que es 2 puntos
71 82 81 82 etcétera etcétera
ven como cada vez nos vamos acercando
más de hecho aquí ya tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 cifras correctas de los valores de eb
así que otro modo de pensar en esto es
decir bueno esto lo voy a pensar como un
límite no voy a pensar como un límite
cuando n tiende a infinito
y este valor este valor lo voy a llamar
y las cifras son casi tan tan
importantes como las cifras de pi
acabamos de ver que él es 2 puntos 71 82
81 18 y algo más pero este número es uno
de los números más bellos y maravillosos
de todas las matemáticas de hecho este
número aparece en el universo en
distintas formas por ejemplo recuerdan
como pierre a la relación que había
entre el perímetro y el diámetro de un
círculo pues también es un número de
este estilo y al igual que pi su
representación decimal continuará nunca
se detiene y nunca se vuelve periódica
de hecho algo que es muy interesante es
que los números como pi y la unidad
imaginaria y esos tres números en bonn
dan en una fórmula maravillosa que
exploraremos en otros vídeos de khan
academy en otros vídeos vamos a estudiar
muchísimo este número
pero bueno resulta extremadamente
interesante que podamos pensar en él
de este modo pensarlo como tomar este
préstamo de un principal de un peso y un
interés del 100 por ciento normal y
simplemente distribuirlo en n períodos
de imposición y hacer ese número n muy
muy grande entonces podríamos pensar por
ejemplo que si sólo tenemos dos periodos
son dos períodos de imposición así que
es cada seis meses estoy componiendo el
interés pero podría pensar que mientras
se me crece podría ser no sé una
composición diaria del interés y luego
una composición cada hora y luego cada
no sé trillonésima del segundo cada vez
más pequeño hasta que este límite sea el
resultado de componer ese interés
continua
en cada instante en cada momento voy a
estar componiendo ese interés